ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata arrivando
l'estate e tutti sappiamo che d'estate
sia meno fame non siamo d'accordo fine
del video è arrivato il momento quindi
di caldo gli farà una ricetta un pochino
più leggera si va al mare si mostra la
pancia col costume intero e per questo
che ho pensato di fare la matriciana uno
spuntino leggero e semplice da portare
in spiaggia basta non evadono
l'amatriciana un pochino come tutti
quanti piatti romani poi parte da un
presupposto ossia che nessuno è
d'accordo sul procedimento vero per
poterla fare c'è chi dice fate in un
modo che ti dice che fanno un'altra
noi abbiamo preso la ricetta di un
signore su youtube di amatrice quanti
anni sarà gianni 102 102 anni di
amatriciana sulle spalle e quindi fatemi
sapere qua sotto ovviamente se avete dei
consigli se l'ha fatto in maniera
diversa ma vi prego non cagate il caffè
criticato sì è vero già miglior pomodori
pelati e io l'ho sempre fatta con i
pelati
tu hai preso la polpa perché
effettivamente perché è stato ripreso
dice mosca anni fa sembra un pomodoro
pelato lui la frullato non si capisce
per fare la matriciana avrete bisogno di
peperoncino
basta ok ma interessante oggi così come
in realtà e spaghetti a tutti voi
fregare solitamente la matriciana
classica richiede ogni spaghetti
rigatoni secondo polpa classica allora
di questo ne sono sicuro guanciale no
pancetta dolce no pancetta affumicata
guanciale guanciale guanciale di maiale
ma pecorino romano dop ma non è di
amatrice questo ero al real pepe
peperoncino porco un poco vino rosso
questi qui perché li ha portati per la
fao i pelati però siccome non è il caso
meglio la polpa vi lasciamo quindi sarà
di gianmarco potete tranquillamente
andare e commentare lui cioè l'odio a
lui qui solamente amore è come sempre ce
lo siamo ricordati siamo stati
bravissimi e arrivato il momento di
indossare il grembiule
[Musica]
la prima cosa che bisogna fare quando si
fa la matriciana è quella di affettare
il guanciale a meno pure detto
teoricamente e l'abbiamo letto sotto
alla carbonara che abbiamo fatto che
teoricamente tu dovresti anche togliere
la parte con il pepe l'hai detto tu vero
perché si annidano batteri e compagnia
bella comunque noi con una stagione di
cucina buttato il miracolo dopo questa
affermazione non so come faccia essere
ancora vivo quante che bisognerebbe
metterne due fetta per se noi facciamo
tutto da me
che domande ma cosa importante cosa
volete farlo a casa è veramente quella
di tagliarlo
per questo test mamma mia desideri nei
pavimenti le fette una sopra l'altra mia
già marc marquez ha fatto il corso di
cucina di notte
i professori qua tutti e per fortuna
questa qui la penultima puntata di
cucina buttata ci prendiamo una pausa
per tendiamo in giro con il willian ho
pensato che la cosa più carina da fare
per celebrare questo fantomatico milione
che tutti quanti diciamo vorrebbero
raggiungere su youtube
ringraziando le persone che mi hanno
aiutato a raggiungerlo abbiamo creato un
google formule persone ci stanno
scrivendo e selezioneremo a caso di
persone alle quali proprio andremo sotto
casa per a bussare per ringraziarle
marino sono arrivati un botto di forma
dio cioè hai rotto lo sgabello cultura
non farei valore dell'energia sono uniti
per bene su fatti male rea cipe di 100
kg o tranquilla per favore si è come i
brand prendono a pancetta la bhutto e
adesso inizia nel momento in cui dovremo
alzare la voce
nel frattempo mentre il nostro guanciale
soffrigge direi di grattare e pecorino
io si è sciolto dentro grattato soa lo
mangio ma a me fa veramente star male e
qui veniamo di staccare il biglietto per
commenti di odio
noi lo so ma poi ci stanno un sacco di
persone che come me la pensano nello
stesso modo la gente che manco
riuscirebbe a mangiarlo
ora diventa così trasparente carinissimo
guarda quanto fantasmi e tira fuori
ecco perché non bisogna mai mettere
l'olio sicuro della polizia l'incidente
atomico
per fortuna c'è gianmarco che ha
studiato tutto quanto può bastare no è
arrivato il momento ma sbaglio siamo
dopo un po e dopo un po dopo tot minuti
sfumate col vino rosso ciechi sfuma col
bianco vero che noi studiamo col rosso
più canto perché mia zia la mamma e
giammarco ci ha obbligato a stare col
rosso solo per questo perché poi noi la
incontriamo dal vivo cioè voi ci mettete
un commento di odio le ci picchia
sei ubriaco dall'area anch'io ragazzi
farà schizzi e vitale di certi che le
vale il guanciale levavano il grasso e
sull'olio che rimaneva sulla padella
auguro ci fa cenno invece butta tutto e
mezzo lui tutto ma egli aggiunge il
bimbo di sale occidente no che schifo
solo giro e poi te lo trovi bravo come
disse bravo a non più di cento cioè
lucini freddo e poi si fa tutta la cena
con l'ansia non la faremo
no non mi dispiace che con tutto
l'affetto del mondo ok mettiamola così
il fuoco a ragazzi sarebbe utile mettere
l'acqua sul fuoco in questi momenti
ma io so ma io non faccio più niente col
peperoncino qualcuno intero se sicuro
si trova
un momento importantissimo quello del
sale quando lo mettete nella pasta
mettetene poco perché sta roba che
spacca le proprie dimostrative nozione
fondamentale il suo deve fare così
jacques jean jacques si chiama
controllo jacques vedere se fosse diviso
noi troppo per non fare più il controllo
chance se fosse liquida sarebbe
hai messo il mestolo di sugo adesso
cucina è sbagliatissimo che corrono
corrono alberghiero che tu hai fatto di
avere diversi metodi uno per girare la
pappa diverso da quello che dirà ma
possono usare anche un terzo mestolo da
infilarti anche detto che cosa abbia
detto sul terzo mestolo e tu che vuoi
fare questo perché così non sia tanto
non si è parlato ma che cosa forse quel
letto ma non ho fatto niente di che ho
aggiunto un pochino di olio nell'acqua
di cottura per evitare che la pasta si
attacchi ok
ok far scorrere l'acqua presa ma non
dobbiamo bloccare la cottura dobbiamo
continuarlo in padella per evitare
non devi mettere l'acqua bollente di
tutto il web vuole vedere saltare questa
pasta
se hai visto bene con i tuoi occhi un po
io ce la metto un po penso che
sarai mamma mia se mario
basta però vi prego uccidete
mamma mia mi si sta spezzando un braccio
ti prego prendimi col cosino quadrato le
sotto e mi faccio un piatto decente voi
vi faccio proprio il piatto quello di
chi non mangia da sette anni
[Applauso]
chissà chi li prenderà tac tac
si capisce di chi sono i piatti
questi sono i tre piatti i nostri
massaggiatori possono per favore entrare
ma no ragazzi perché schifo tutta sta
roba qui
356 pronti ma vai
leggo dei commenti e dà fastidio ad
asseggiano per questi microfoni
esperimento riuscito bene
se volete riparla anche voi
secondo la ricetta e magari fate una
foto una storia nella quale intaccate su
instagram che per me sempre molto
divertente per impostarli ma anche solo
guardarvi potervi rispondere per ridere
con voi dire una parola che sono loro
che ridono
di me e tu non mangi allora come sempre
invito a scrivere da questo canale mi
fareste un grande favore siete super
gentili anche se attivate la campanella
delle notifiche qua sotto in modo da non
perdere eventuali uscite future che
altro dire noi ci vediamo la prossima
domenica con l'ultima puntata di cucina
buttata di questa stagione
sempre alle 12 ciao